what's up guys today we're gonna do
something groundbreaking
never-before-seen on the Internet
talk about star wars everybody's
speculating what's gonna happen in
Episode seven forget that we're gonna
tell you what needs to happen and we
have an awesome panel of Star Wars mega
fans to help us out first from The
Upright Citizens Brigade theater and
Reno 9-1-1
and you know him from belated media he's
the man behind the massively popular
what-if episode one were good what if
episode two was good Michael barity
Michael thanks for being here thank you
so much for having me let's talk about
the what if they were good videos what
kind of reaction are you getting from
the fans for the most part incredibly
positive because I think myself and
everybody else went into all those
prequel films really hoping for great
things nobody goes to the movies because
they want a film to suck so Justin as
someone who camped out
- what waiting to watch these films what
did you think of them well I've actually
learned to love episode 1 but at the
time when I first saw it it was the
worst experience of my life so clearly
we all have some degree of trauma from
these prequels but Lucas is gone they're
starting over episode 7 what do we want
to see there are a few things that we
don't want to see everybody who has been
a part of the original trilogy
theoretically could be back I don't know
if that's a good idea who of those do we
really want to see Justin do you have
any thoughts I want to see everybody
yeah I want to see absolutely everybody
but to what degree do you want to see I
want them to be the only people in the
movie really yes are you saying you're
serious yeah I am dead serious oh I
haven't even considered that option and
I didn't see that coming from you that
is not supposed to be funny or ironic
that is really what I want to see when I
called you and asked you want to do this
you didn't say you were gonna come in
with those what they said I have a
difference of opinion than most people
you do and um let's pick Michael who
wants to expand the universe again
to you so to speak who wants to cling to
who an elderly Carrie Fisher you don't
want her in the slave layout fit do you
yeah why not
god forbid all right all right versus
versus Michael if you would please sit
here stay right there you are an enemy
of the state all right Wow
Michael you strike me as a level-headed
man what do you have to say about this
like I have absolutely no problem with
revisiting areas and characters but I
don't think they should be the entirety
of what seven eight and nine are going
to be because if we just have an
overabundance of hey here's the grab bag
of everything from your memories and
childhood does that mean Darth Vader and
Palpatine and Darth Maul yes okay that's
where we okay
no no because to me the Star Wars films
are not just a series of good and bad
movies when we were kids we saw the
original three movies they filled you
with hopes and dreams then in your late
teens early 20s the prequels came around
and you were smacked in the face with
the reality of life but maybe not all
your dreams are gonna come true and not
everything is going to be okay that the
prequels did this to me the prequels
made it so that I cannot look forward to
or hope for good movies anymore yes
that's powerful
Star Wars really did a number on your
head man yeah yeah if we're going with
the idea that this is taking place 30 or
40 years in the future I'm fine with
seeing them as themselves yeah but
seeing Luke swing a lightsaber around
isn't going to be as God that's the last
thing I the last thing I want to see is
Mark Hamill in a lightsaber battle
present a did you hear anyone
complaining about how all the people
were in cocoon none terrible argument
great reference Justin you really made
us think today I want to turn to Michael
now just for a moment tell me what you
think needs to happen with episode 7
well I'm absolutely fine with seeing
some of those old characters return
however it should be again
new characters being introduced to these
characters interact with and then they
become our leads also the threat of the
Empire now being somewhat forted should
be coming from a different angle
not just the dark side let me ask you
this what about an overall turn to kind
of the gravity the mythology that is
Star Wars
I think episode 7 is going to have a bit
more lightness to it than the original
trilogy yeah however there's going to be
the darkness brooding in the back that's
going to be like Oh despite the fact
that we have this New Republic evil
still exists and now we have to rise up
and face this challenge Justin what you
really want aside do you can you see
them bridging the gap and getting back
to a little bit of the gravity of the
old films yeah I could totally see that
I think one thing we haven't touched
upon is what these movies are gonna
actually look like because the prequels
don't look anything like the original
trilogy we've already had mentioned that
they're shooting it on film they're
using more practical effects in terms of
both sets and creature design to my
understanding so that tangible aesthetic
should be there and look you know if
they can make something that looks and
feels like the original trilogy then I
can come around to your side and I can
be totally open to new stories new
characters new adventures this episode
has been very exciting but now we're
gonna give you an Internet exclusive
we're gonna tell you what the titles of
Episode seven eight and nine are going
to be brought in a wheel that is a Star
Wars title generator it's filled with
jargon Gungans hope jedi and so on and
so forth alright let's find out the
title of episode seven hope attack there
you have it Episode seven attack of the
hope episode eight sis clones and
finally episode nine Disney I hope
you're listening
Jedi Empire to recap episode 7 attack of
the hope episode 8 Sith clones episode 9
Jedi Empire
you're welcome everyone oh I thank my
awesome panelists for really bringing it
today Justin thank you for your
extraordinary views Michael thank you
for being here sir check out his videos
belated media so what do you want to see
happen in the upcoming Star Wars movies
and who do you think was right leave a
comment in the section below best answer
gets a $25 Best Buy gift card
brought to you by cinnamon al from Best
Buy I want to thank you for watching I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
that was picked Michael Jordan this and
one space oh he cornered the market got
the best basketball player who was
better than Jordan Teen Wolf
he's got ridiculous ups he could surf on
top of a van